what jp morgan is doing very offensive
what they're doing over there so here we
go
uh graduates should expect to work
12-hour days six days a week to really
master their job says
j.p morgan executive a business insider
story graduate wealth management analyst
should expect to work 72 hours a week
and they'll be better trained for it
according to
mary callahan erdos the ceo of jpmorgan
chase's asset and wealth management
division based on the idea that it takes
roughly ten thousand hours to gain
base level mastery of something that's
going to take around five years if
somebody works 80 hour eight hour days
five days a week she said on wall street
it takes it's more like 12 hour days six
days a week
that cuts you down to about two and a
half years before you masturbate
something and i love the fact that
they're just open about it
in 2013 an intern of bank of america
merrill lynch's london office died of a
seizure
while it was conclusive an inquest
concluded that overwork could have
contributed to
21 year old moritz erdhot uh
his death unfortunate story obviously
there but the fact that the ceo is
openly saying if you want to make it
it's
12-hour days six days a week to cut down
the mastering the skill set in
half the time two and a half years adam
your thoughts on this i'm totally okay
with this as long as it's full
disclosure before you get the job think
about who's taking these jobs
very uh established you know you
think somebody's taking this job not
knowing those three hours that's what
i'm saying they know this
of course no no don't take the job
exactly yeah look why are you taking
this job because you want to make
money because you want to make money
yeah it's a tough job
so if you're saying that it typically
takes five years to do this now you can
do this in two and a half years you
graduate you're 22 you're 23. by the
time you're 25 you put in the
crazy hours you're 25 you've made money
you're you're an expert
i believe it was malcolm gladwell that
says you need to put in 10 000 hours
um to be an expert at something and if
you can do it in half the time
and by the time you're 25 you're an
established expert in a field
by the time you're 30 you'll have multi
millions in the bank i think a lot of
people would want to do this
yes you're sacrificing your early 20s
and yes there's burnout and burnout is
real
but you know what you're getting
yourself into if that's a job you're
taking
i call [ __ ] i think it's nonsense
that you're gonna take your lowest wage
employees
grind them into dust whoever makes it
makes it whoever does it wasn't worth it
you know meanwhile jamie dimon's getting
another freaking billion dollars or
whatever they're giving him
you know these aren't their lowest wage
employees these are right out of college
these are the lowest wage people right
these are
people fresh out of six figures these
are they're making sure these are
wealth management analysts these are not
your your local
intern so this is this is not the best
they're like at the bottom of the food
chain well they're starting out at the
bottom
in the wealth management sector look
i i think these are people anybody that
graduated from harvard business school i
would say this time to grind if there's
work to do do the work what i don't like
is
i've been in environments where the
culture is we're there from eight to
eight
and then people sandbag their way
through today not doing work because
they think they're gonna be there all
day
and that's what baseball we used to call
eyewash eyewash is like when people just
sit there doing nothing until they think
the coach is watching then they start
shuffling the papers and it's like oh
i'm doing work work work work look at me
working so hard
no like look if you have work to do do
work now i don't i didn't come
up in the financial industry i came up
in creative so
it was the exact opposite for us we just
you got paid for a project
and the best directors the best
producers that i was on it was like hey
we got the project done if we got all
our shots
get out of here we're not getting paid
by the hour like it's it's in that case
it's a race
you know when you do a commercial and
you've got two days and you've got you
know
essentially 20 hours two two shoot days
and then if you get done by 16 hours you
got all your shots and you got all your
pickups and everything like that
you're paying you're paying your crew
extra so what ends up happening the same
crew comes back multiple times
and they get better and better and
better and more efficient at their job
because they know if i do my job and i
do it well we're getting out of here i
don't have to be here until
midnight tonight i'm going to get out of
here at 8 o'clock so i've seen it from
the other side
if you guys i haven't been in that
position so i should i shouldn't have
had such a
a strong opinion on that from the
beginning i do apologize for that but if
if there is 12 hours worth of work to do
do the work compete i'm all for that but
if you're just setting an environment
where this is this is not the
environment
where you're sitting around buddy let me
put it this is like paper pushing sure
you you
you're it's a little bit of a reach but
i get it your world you're in
your world is not uh this world your
word the
world is project based you go finish the
project you're done i get it that's the
optics that's the part you're in
in this world if you're gonna sit around
the 12 hours at the office and do
nothing
you will be fired in 90 days
this is not a job for you bro morgan
stanley dean witter your first year if
you and this is an
this is an 0-1 when i got the job 20
years ago
if you didn't bring 10 million dollars
your first year in you're
fired if you didn't pass your series 7
the first time not second third time
morgan merrill goldman you have to pass
it the first time you don't you're fired
right
if you don't pass it the first time
you're fired if you don't get 10 million
dollars your first year you're fired
there is no time to sit around and shoot
the [ __ ] and look at instagram videos
all day long and tick tock and two other
twitter videos you do that it's over
with
you have to go out there network you
have to go out there shake hands you
have to go out there in the morning you
have to go out there to the
country club you have to drive the
appointments you have to you have to do
anything and everything it takes to be
a winner in this job so what does that
12 hours look like what is that 12 hours
it's non-stop you're either prospecting
you're either looking for clients you're
either networking
you have to be around or you're
analyzing you're doing you're doing data
analytics
you're learning about what's going on
you're studying everything in the market
what's going on you're studying the
papers you're trying to see
what this analyst is saying what that
analyst is saying what just what's an
official
buy what's a hold what's a cell what
just change categories who got a better
rating
whose quarterly calls coming up let me
see what this guy's going to be doing
but
most of this job is shaking hands being
in front of people are you actually
managing the wealth
my understanding was that there were
programs like there's a goldman
fund that you go into and they and you
you get into this and you get it like
so what why would i go with for example
okay why would i go with
you know uh jp morgan instead of
western mutual why why would i go you're
gonna you you
everybody here brags that they have the
best money manager they have the best
fund they have the best whatever so
you're putting
you're gambling where you're putting
your money with goldman's gonna say
we're the best because you are able to
participate in certain things that
others are not like goldman says
to to get into goldman to have an
account with them to manage your money
it's 10 million
yeah i was going to say you ain't got 10
million you can be this is goldman
doesn't let you get in
with less than 10. we're not doing the
ten thousand dollar buy-in that's bank
of america
goldman sachs goldman is going to be the
10 billion dollar client but if you're
with goldman here's what happens with
goldman
you want an ipo to participate in uber
before anybody else is done yeah you can
go in how much you want to put in half a
million great you can go on because
you're part of the goldman family
those types of opportunities comes to
you but you know how many total advisors
goldman sachs goldman has
how many think goldman has no idea maybe
under 500.
400 go 400 that is all goldman's
goldman sachs the united states are
worldwide in u.s
goldman sachs's office in dallas
is half the size of this office 10
estate
they have 10 annual analysis they have
400 financial advisors
is what they have that is it to get a
job with goldman there's probably a lot
more in california
to florida versus you have to be the
cream of the crop
now if you make it at goldman five years
later minimum
seven figure under if you're there ten
years and you're a killer
you can make five ten fifteen twenty you
can make money if you're at a place like
that
but is it easy to make it and stay there
absolutely not so
again if you want to you know we we we
look at sports and you're like hey to
get to the next level it takes a lot
okay four questions are you clear on
what you want to do with your life your
dreams your goals
number one most people are not i asked
this question last week in dallas
how many of you are clear everybody's
hands went up i said great i'm gonna ask
a question one more time
how many guys are so clear about your
dreams and goals
that if i bring you up on stage you can
recite it to everybody in 20 seconds
this is what happened
a thousand people in the room 50 hands
are up it was 800 hands up when i asked
it openly
then when there was a commitment to you
coming and presenting it to everybody
else their hands went up that's okay
great
so most of you guys don't even know what
your dreams and goals are i know what it
is to be there i've been there before as
well number two
let's just say you know what your dreams
and goals are do you know how demanding
that dream or goal is to become a
reality so a person says what
yes or what no i don't know how to
manage i want to do this like i don't
know how long it's going to take don't
know how demanding it is
oh yeah i want to make a millionaire do
you really know what it takes
like we talked about nobody takes this
job not knowing how much work they're
going to work
you know how demanding it is to be
that person it's a lot of work the
greatest of the greatest comedians that
i read about and i go
see what they did they freaking had no
life for five
ten years they went out it's like
maniacal it's not the best
life the people who went and played in
the military and guys made it to the top
dude they were doing correspondence
afterwards
i wasn't doing correspondence afterwards
matter of fact i can tell you there's
two and a half years in the military
i've never taken one correspondence
class my buddy took correspondence
classes he retired as a delta force
i got out as an e4 i was not taking
military seriously so i didn't have like
a
hey i'm going to go take a correspondent
so let me go back at it how clearly are
you about your dreams and goals number
one number two
how demanding is that dream like if it's
to win an emmy if it's to win an oscar
how demanding is that
number three is the tough question that
everybody secretly answers that nobody
knows you know what the question is
are you willing to meet
the demand required to have
your dreams and goals and vision become
a reality
and most the answer is what secretly
they say what i'm just not willing to do
it
i'd much rather go home and party and
the last one is the following and then
i'm gonna turn it over to you
the last one is when you sit there you
close your eyes
and you dream about whatever your vision
is whatever your dream is to become a
reality you're by yourself when you
think about it
does it get you emotional does it get
you fired up
does it get you to say oh my gosh like
you you get the chills all over your
body
if it doesn't it's not really that big
of a dream so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye